let's get a fashion shot now listen the
pressures on yep let me see your shoes
no cuz you're presenting so I want to
know what shoe we have oh you know
you're good thank you it's not too
difficult of a shoe let me actually look
at the bottom all the price tags on the
grapes
I'm wearing problem I don't know the
shoes sorry Stuart Weitzman do it very I
got you thank you there's pressure
tonight
yeah because Tracee Ellis Ross can't
host the show forever
so I mean you're gonna do a damn good
job yeah maybe next year could be your
year like you got to take your moment
this is my audition tape this year I'm
presenting the Syrah so we'll see how
this goes I know that you had a lot of
fun with a lot of celebrities at the Met
Gala and now you're gonna see them all
again tonight is there anyone you're
like oh god I saw you at the Met Gala
and you weren't wearing pants so now
we're here at the AMA now we are they
amaze I'm excited to see Arianna because
she inspired me tonight I'm half re
right now so I'm excited to see her
again and just congratulate her on all
her success and Khalid I love you
[Music]